45 years ago princess leia the first
hologram in history and today we are
announcing that leia has come true and
you can send your hologram in real time
into the extended reality devices using
just a smartphone
i am ceo and co-founder of matsuko we
make holograms
matsuko is the closest solution to
face-to-face meetings even when the
distance sets us apart
you can imagine like a
ceo of a company talking to his or her
employees using matsuko you can be you
the real you not an animated avatar
and we bring the complexity of the whole
capture studios into simple mobile apps
so all you need to do is to open our app
and now you can see others as holograms
in 3d all you need is a smartphone
[Music]
i'm coming from a very small city called
koshitse in the heart of europe in
slovakia
many our friends didn't come because
they are helping ukrainians because we
are very close to the border i decided
to come because it's only a week and
it's a great opportunity to pitch
maybe win on the south by southwest
pitch award
yes
we'll see i don't i don't think we will
win but
maybe
never know
how do you feel congratulations
yeah thank you very much so we won the
south by southwest pitch competition i'm
so proud of our team because it's a
great motivation for us it shows us that
people
are ready for holograms and we
it's like a dream that came true
[Music]